people need to know what they should do
and one of the things they should do is
take responsibility have you heard of
Jordan Peterson he's a psychologist who
lectures about responsibility I assumed
that would bore young people yet
millions watch his videos and buy his
book twelve rules is unbelievably
successful number one on Amazon that
almost never happens with nonfiction
yeah well it's also a difficult book you
know it's a dark book as well so it's
not it's not the sort of thing that you
would expect people to line up to buy
and yet they do they line up in long
lines excited says Peterson to learn
about responsibility young men get
excited when you talk to them about
responsibility yeah you know fancy daddy
who would have ever guessed that I
wouldn't have no no kidding
no kidding the emergence of ethical
behavior when Peterson first rented a
lecture hall he didn't know if anyone
would listen to him speak do you imagine
this a as an invitation to a lecture
okay we're going to talk about the Old
Testament in a really dark way like you
think that's going to be successful and
we're gonna talk about responsibility
and truth oh they'll be beating down the
doors to attend those lectures and well
they all sold out his lectures continue
selling out because he says people have
been fed this this diet of pablum rights
and impulsive freedom free tuition
making quality childcare affordable all
we've had for 60 years is a dialogue
about rights there's a just an absolute
starvation for the other side of this
story well that leaves a hole in
people's hearts Collin Peterson fills
that hole with things he learned from
his clinical psychology practice it's in
responsibility that most people find the
meaning that sustains them through life
it's not in happiness it's not an
impulsive pleasure instead he says the
way to find meaning is to adopt the
responsibility for your own well-being
and to try to put your family together
and to try to serve your community and
to try to seek for eternal truths and to
live them that's the sort of thing that
can ground you in in your life enough so
that you can
stand the difficulty of life research
backs him up people feel fulfilled when
they feel competent it's very helpful
for people to hear that they should make
themselves competent and dangerous and
take the proper place in the world
competent and dangerous mm-hmm
why dangerous there's nothing to you
otherwise like if you're not a
formidable force there's not there's no
morality in your self control if you're
incapable of violence not being violent
isn't a virtue people who teach martial
arts know this full well if you learn a
martial art you learn to be dangerous
but simultaneously you learn to control
it
because it's the alternative to being
weak I even weak and harmless which is
what young men are being encouraged to
be encouraged says Peterson by educators
and media that bash masculinity the
problem is toxic masculinity toxic
masculinity you were alienating young
men we're telling them that they're
patriarchal oppressors that's a bad
message this Peterson life is a very
difficult process and you're not
prepared for it unless unless you have
the capacity for to be dangerous by
dangerous that implies I should be ready
to threaten someone to hurt somebody no
you should be capable of it but that
doesn't mean you should use it your
female critics say you men are already
stronger than a weight you abused us and
you're encouraging that you know well
that's definitely not the case but lots
of people call Peterson's sexist
transphobic evil from Vox
have claimed feminists have an
unconscious wish for brutal male
domination now you tell me why they line
up with the Islamists not all do they
just haven't criticized them well that's
good enough for me you know you'd think
if the if the feminists practice what
they preach there'd be non-stop
demonstrations against Saudi Arabia
Saudi women they still cannot get
married travel abroad or open a bank
account without permission of a male
guardian you see how much concern there
is among the radical feminists for the
rights of women others dismiss him as
shallow articles call him a charlatan
the stupid man smart person peddling
fascist mysticism because comments
toughen up you weasel and compassion as
a vice provide philosophical backup -
demagogues like Donald Trump these fire
compassion is a vice if it's taken too
far hyper protectiveness helicopter
parenting all of that when you have
children you have to encourage them to
take risks because they have to grow up
and take their place in the world you
can't protect them too much because if
you do you destroy them and that's a
message that leads millions of people to
buy this book and line up to here Jordan
Peterson speak